[Laughter]
link me the [__]
dog all right everybody and uh and we're
live for this episode of the weekly poll
Q&A welcome to the uh the weekly pull uh
Q&A episode uh I am Benny from the comic
storian um I am joined today by our
usual co-hosts uh Marvel explained AKA
Robert Jefferson and uh TV little house
uh being represented by S CR crev Val
and that was close enough Sal clli is my
name and I represent TV little house
because I am TV little house he is TV
little house no one else here Ben
Ethan so what we would like to do today
is um we we want to have a Q&A episode
because uh Rob just did a rather
successful AMA over at the reddits um I
hear that as a quite popular Forum
system um but he just did a AMA over
there that was quite successful and
there was a slew of comments that came
our way well his way and so now we
decided new move to go ahead and give
you guys a Q&A with the entire cast of
the the weekly PLL um because honestly
it's Thanksgiving weekend and we're too
lazy to look up topics so it's true well
no it's it's really that the uh the the
tree has dried up there's no fruit it's
um I believe Wonder Woman has a director
who gives a crap about that and uh you
know the comics are just kind of it's
kind of sitting there well we could we
could discuss uh axis again but uh
nothing nothing's
happening we couldn't we've exhausted
that topic you sp 5 minutes talking
about access you've exhausted every
topic about access well we we could also
talk about uh um the uh the the the DC
event um world end uh weekly book wait
no okay no we cannot uh that's uh that
that's done that's done I don't know
what you're talking about but uh but
welcome to the show everybody so uh go
ahead and start slamming us with
questions and I'll ask the first
official one um over with uh um uh Rob
over there um uh Rob uh I need to know
uh what are your opinions of uh the uh
Jurassic World
trailer well um after sitting down and
and watching the trailer oddly enough
while I was uh getting ready this
morning um I was very very satisfied
with it you know after going back and
watching uh Jurassic Park 1 which was
pretty fantastic of a of a movie
Spielberg did a really good job and then
um you know going back and and watching
Jurassic Park 2
oh where so I'm not sorry about that I'm
I'm very much happy about having seen
that everything up until like halfway
through the movie so right you know when
like the T-Rex showed up in the city
that was pretty awesome that that was
not that was the only awesome part of
that movie that was not very awesome
part I thought that was a um Godzilla
spin-off but okay um that's that's what
a lot of people thought is that it was a
Godzilla spin-off which makes sense
because you know like it was it was a
stupid idea but um you know we got
around to Jurassic Park 3 you know which
of course was just uh one of the worst
things to ever been conceived of by men
and uh I thought that was Twilight okay
we'll go with right I'd say I'd say
they're about equal about equal at this
point and um then I sat down and and I
looked at the trailer and I said wow
well it has Chris Pratt so you know I
mean he was he was Star-Lord so chances
are it's not going to suck so you know
um I guess we'll see what happens but uh
you know he's been in one thing I like
so that that that must be some
indication that he's awesome I mean
that's you know that's you know Screw
you for saying that but has a whole
bunch of romantic comedies that bombed
other than that Rob uh that's I'm not uh
I I'd say don't worry about that I'd say
uh you know mind your business do you
think Gro start in the movie it would be
better I I think I think uh a giant tree
walking around saying I am Gro and being
eaten by T-Rex would be pretty awesome
true either that either that like he
would walk out and he would go to greet
like a Stegosaurus and the stegosaurus
would just start eating him and you'll
be pretty awesome I believe
stegosauruses were
vegetarians um Tyler re like to comment
of this is so this is really funny
because my Town's NPR station has been
out of service um all day so he still
gets his um daily dose of softspoken
white people
uh before we start taking uh but guys
ask any questions any questions at all
we we want to go over them with you um
and we will answer as many as we
possibly can within our hour hour and a
half time block um but we would like to
ask I want to ask one question to the
two of you have either one of you U read
the new um Guardians of the Galaxy book
no um no I've I've done the absolute
best that I can and I've been pretty
successful at doing that but I've done
the best that I can to stay away from
the new Guardians of the Galaxy refering
to the Bendis book are you talking about
the spin-off books no no no no the
Bendis book the one where it ends with
um uh Groot being taken over by the
Phenom symet uh I missed that one but I
have been reading since issue one
actually I've been no I've been
religiously reading that book uh it's
been fun kind of except that it's also
unfortunately been a casualty of every
Marvel event that has taken place since
I guess two years ago it's taken 20
issues to move the plot forward and the
actual Guardians of the Galaxy book yeah
yeah it's pretty bad but uh I did not
see group become venom but that
certainly sounds like a forum post uh or
a tweet at Bendis that said wouldn't it
be rad if group became
Venom I'm just just gonna put this over
there for you guys okay either that
either that we're talking about a
situation whereby um Brian Michael
Bendis had uh hung out with some friends
that he hasn't seen for a number of
years they were fraternity fraternity
brothers and they really never moved on
with their lives or never really did
anything with themselves and he was like
hey man you guys want to hang out and
they were like yeah man we haven't seen
you let's catch up and so he went over
there and and they got really high and U
Bendis was just stoned out of his mind
and looked over at one of his friends
and said hey man like Venom Groot like
you know got two words for you guys guys
keep it down keep it down it's rather L
you know and my mom my mom will get mad
if I wake her up so we need we need to
keep soft spoken s spoken yeah soft
spoken yeah soft we need to keep it soft
spoken um okay that I imagine that's
exactly how that went down is that bis
just got got really high high really
really high um so for everybody just
joining us now I do want to give an
official one more time opening welcome
to the weekly poll podcast I am one of
your hosts uh Benny from the comic story
and uh joined by our co-host Rob from
Marble explain and TV little house from
TV little house uh um I I want to take
this moment to remind everyone that
January 1st we are launching www.the
weekly poll. ninja which is going to be
your entertainment source for comic
books featuring a lot of your favorite
comic book personalities including
myself Marvel xplain TV Little House
comic Drake and now joined by its super
effective fa over there on the UK who
apparently doesn't wake up any earlier
than like really late for us so um but
that will be joining us soon so I hope
you guys are looking forward to that and
today's episode because it's
Thanksgiving we're going to give thanks
to you all of our loyal viewers um of
all of our channels and do a Q&A and
we'll answer any questions that don't
involve Sal's pants so uh that was a
conversation starter we we tried out it
didn't it didn't quite work and we're
going to try with the the softspoken MPR
style of of recording and if it doesn't
work out as it probably won't um we will
increase the volume as we go uh so be
prepared if you need to reduce the
volume of your speakers because I may
have woken up your mother um all right
so uh
the Jake lionhardt would like to know uh
our opinions on the apocalypse casting
um since I am completely unaware of this
uh why don't you to take point in this
because um you both decided to uh
mention at the beginning of our lovely
podcast while I sip on some lovely
spring
water well um that water probably came
from like a real spring too oh no doubt
I'm I'm in Colorado everything is legit
and organic over here
so
marij
organic no they they have uh they've
officially announced the uh the casting
of the titular villain Apocalypse in the
X-Men apocalypse film will be played
none other than uh o Oscar Isaac who's
an actor I don't recognize in any way
nor do I care about oh my God I also
couldn't care less about apocalypse I
think he's more of a more of a plot
device than a character and uh also I
think the days of Apocalypse spin Days
of Future Past kind of uh kind of
wrapped up the X-Men movie franchise I
feel like what are we
doing let's just give it to martle how
about move on you can't do it
anymore but here we go it'll also
undermine the ending of Days of Future
Past I don't want to spoil it so I won't
but check it out it's on Blue right now
pick it up did you just plug a a actual
product that we're not going to make any
money off of uh there's no way we would
ever make money off of that product
that's a
it's a fox
product very true very true uh Marvel
explained what what are your opinions on
the uh the casting of Apocalypse yeah um
the first thing I'd like to say is that
with uh s's comment regarding um
apocalypse being a plot device I think
you should just go uh drown yourself in
a river um I think
that'll this is going to be the most
volatile NPR show anyone has ever heard
in their life true this has been this
has been pretty wild so far we've been
pretty pretty outrageous so I can't
believe that we've gone N9 minutes and
not one of us has spoken up no true um I
would say that um that Isaac or that
Oscar Isaac is is a pretty fantastic
actor and uh I recognize him but I can't
place what he's ever been in but that
doesn't mean that he's not a fantastic
actor I know that what I know that what
he was in was really cool I just can't
remember what it was but um you know I
uh I uh I'm really looking forward to uh
to probably the most formidable villain
in the history of the X-Men being a uh
being in a film um he's really cool and
and I've always been a big fan
especially after watching the TV show so
uh you mean you mean the cartoon show uh
I I prefer to call it a TV show but you
can call it a cartoon show if you want
to I'm pretty sure falls under animation
which does and in fact actually fall
under the category of a cartoon show
Marvel explained um it was a show that
was on TV so you know a TV show makes
sense look the Japanese review their
cartoons I don't see any you know well
this this
they have an entire genre known as anime
um in which they actually do a whole
bunch of you know cartoons and they
treat it
as we know I mean if you uh if you guys
want to be dicks about it then yeah I
guess it was a cartoon show you know by
the way for the record Oscar Isaacs was
in uh Robin Hood starring Russell Crow
he played Prince John he was he was in
the uh fantastic film Sucker
Punch um he was the guy in it and uh he
was also in
Drive yes he was and for the record so
everybody knows s does not know that off
the top of his head he pulled up Wiki
actually was IMDb but yeah oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry your resources are much faster
than mine so the next question that we
have is being asked by Jake lionhart and
uh okay well it's the same car guy but
we have others after this but his
question is what is our origin story um
how did we get into the YouTube Avengers
casting
um you know what uh so Rob do you want
to take this or do you want me to do it
um I can do it
epically uh I think that that that in
your epic radio voice um I'd say okay
you know take it away okay welcome to
the complete story for the YouTube
Avengers a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away there was a YouTuber known as
Robert Jefferson also known as fluidic
beats and there was another YouTuber
known as eligible monster both of them
were trying to perform video game
oriented content while fluing beats did
not see any form of success eligible
monster saw a very very minor amount of
success to the point of possibly getting
out of his full-time job and doing this
as a full-time career on YouTube
eventually uh eligible monster decided
to dabble into the world of comic books
but fuic Beats beat him to the punch and
decided to do the exact same thing as
Marvel explained well eventually as
Marvel explained grew in popularity uh
he decided that he was going to launch a
podcast and his first thought was to
bring in viewers and discuss comic book
topics but by the F of a
watcher
U he Mar you want to you ass I know I
was hoping you were G to catch it
you he was directed I'm doing it as a as
a comic story and epic thing and if I do
that I got to mispronounce one thing
anyway fair enough um Marvel xplain was
directed to the channel known as comic
storian that had just Rec recently
launched with six complete stories
explaining story arcs seeing this as an
opportunity to talk to a fellow comic
book Enthusiast YouTuber Marvel explain
invited him to join a podcast and
eventually the YouTube Avengers were
started with their sidekick Dave now
eventually as they grew Marvel explained
got a little overzealous and wanted to
invite about 10 people onto the podcast
but fear not comic story put a stop to
this and said we should invite probably
two of them this eventually became known
as the invitation to TV little house it
was an age of apocalypse events in which
the entire YouTube Avengers were
decimated and in this happening Dave was
killed
Now Dave died at at the End of the Age
of Apocalypse the YouTube Avengers
reformed into a more formidable Force
involving the likes of comic Drake and
now in a in a very soon future number
one issue it's super
effective by the way can I say I love
his voice it is amazing super effective
yeah oh yeah yeah I'm always so dazzled
by uh by the English accent it is it is
quite amazing I do I do I'm actually
more shocked about by our our new uh
Adventure is uh his hairstyles how they
change yeah it is fantastic I wish I
could do that with my hair I don't I
would look like a fraking [__] but uh
he manages to put off really well he
does really do he does okay and I would
just look goofy as [__] I think he's
also half my age so that would also be
probably a reason why I shouldn't
if Robert had grow his hair out to the
length of it's super effective he would
just have a giant clown fro in Mar's
colors I'd like to see that I think I'd
like to see that too I think I might go
ahead and uh yeah grow it out give that
a shot see how that comes out grow it
out just pick it all just sit here in
the podcast just pick it out the whole
time and yeah be awesome pick just pick
out just pick out my hair the whole
time okay um it's terminal Noob no sorry
his name is just terminal Noob would
like to know what we're thankful for
this Thanksgiving um Marvel explain why
don't you take point on this
discussion um well you know I think the
the first thing I should say here is
that I'm thankful for uh having a
successful YouTube channel and uh more
importantly than that I'm thankful for
being as awesome as I am um but thankful
for
myself um for the success that I've
brought to to all of our success because
I'm the reason you guys are successful
and um you know I uh I think that it's
like the most [__] response ever I'm
the greatest thing slice bread and I
would like to take this moment to
announce my departure from this
group uh starting immediately so
bye no we we we love you guys out in the
chat so uh yeah so yeah you guys are are
success so good enough to me um Mr
little house uh yeah uh my my I'm
incredibly thankful for uh you guys for
bringing me aboard for for the uh the
incredible um my incredible co-hosts Ben
and Ethan and making me look as good as
I possibly could on what we do uh those
two really bring out whatever whatever
magic was in there and uh that they're
the ugly friends so that you look good
oh no I'm the ugly one
they but they make me look good by
comparison oh okay um and uh and I'm
really thankful for our viewers
particularly you know the ones who who
who share you know their opinions and
their feelings it's really been uh
incredibly rewarding for me as a Creator
to you know really get this direct comp
uh you know communication with people
and uh and and seeing them React to what
we do it's really been an amazing
experience and I I couldn't be more
thankful for
it um I'm I'm thankful for uh how
amazing I am and every way she perform
um I can't I can't Rob stole my joke I
can't do it I can't do it now I was
gonna be the [__] I'm always the
[__] well fine I'm thankful for my
dashing good looks um can argue with
that no I I'm thankful for all the
viewers also um I'm thankful for Robin
and S here because without them I don't
think any of us would have gotten where
we are and I think we compliment each
other quite well uh I'm thankful for the
fact that I have a comic book store five
minutes away and I'm able to just go
pick up $40 of comic books a
week pretty good feeling it is to drive
over there and pick up comic books um
I'm also thankful that uh we're doing
stuff that we enjoy and this is how how
far along it's come we get to we get to
do what we enjoy and I I'm really really
thankful for that um I'm also thankful
for this amazing voice that God has
given me so you should thank God for
that every day my friend that is that
now I will be struck down with strep
throat and lose my voice and
something
yeah that sounds awesome yeah let's take
another question okay the next question
is s needs more subs help him out don't
think that's question but you know what
incredibly valid totally worth talking
about um I agree entirely nor and rad
thank you and good luck with your Cosmic
surfing it's been uh working out for you
so
far sorry Dan slot is making you into
Doctor Who but whatever he really is and
that's why I'm liking it
anyway I I read the first issue of uh
the new Silver Surfer book and I was
just like I don't like Doctor Who so I
don't care about what's happening Joe
Shadow DJ is thankful for a Marvel
explained making him less making him a
less of a filthy casual through your
videos Rob much obliged um I don't think
there's anything wrong with being a uh a
casual comic book reader
um there's a lot of people who learn
their stuff just by uh reading Wikipedia
which
is like a terrible way to learn your
stuff because anybody can edit it I mean
they could edit to say that like Captain
America is an actual person that somehow
got trapped in the world of comic books
and you know or that apocalypse is a
horrible villain but whatever yeah or
apocalypse is a plot device as s had
incorrectly stated earlier it's think
it's an opinion but okay uh well there's
there is such a thing as wrong opinions
you know if you knew that we're all a
bit quiet today and B uh today we're
doing a MPR thing we're going to see how
long we can keep these low voices so
yeah oh but it's actually hurting my
voice of talking like that so yeah it's
true yeah it is all right all right
hands on done it's
dropped all right welcome back to the
weekly poll I think we 20 minutes for 20
minutes your viewers are going to be
like you guys put me to sleep what the
hell was that like people are like
showing up and bailing out they're like
man [__] that noise like this is the
lowest viewer count you've ever had on a
we yeah it's it's it's pitiful man like
it's it's awful like they're gonna be
like no I want loud people talking about
Comics I don't like it unsubscribe
oh I don't how every time someone
portrays like a troll on the internet
that's how it always is like oh I've
noticed that like cuz I'll be sitting
there typing like like oh yeah no you
know that was a great video Rob and then
I watch next be like Rob
suck yeah that's that's what I had like
during my AMA like like people were
getting on and they were just saying
like like off the wall and rude stuff
like they were like that was that was do
what about you in general yeah somebody
was like like kill yourself in real life
and I'm like why like why why would I do
that
like good I mean I don't understand why
would do that yeah well no the
suggestion yeah I was like yourself in
real life when else would I kill myself
I would like it stated that the real
zubs is thankful
that'ss and TV Little House Comics
responded with thankful for zubs for
making my life worth living yeah my
girlfriend jumped into the chat I
noticed and reminded me that uh most of
the things I do are dependent on her
so um okay uh Jo Joe Shadow DJ is now
going to go to the wiki to read all of
his comic knowledge thanks for turning
away a viewer Marvel
explained I mean
it's okay you know fine that's how you
want to be in you
that oh um okay so let's go up here and
look at some actual things uh for those
of you who are just now joining us or
have been with us for a little while you
might want to turn your spikers down now
power turn really loud to hear our joke
that we did for way too long one of you
two are supposed to put an end to it at
some point I don't know why you kept
going had to um I mean I thought it was
a funny idea it was good yeah but nobody
was
watching yeah that's true people were
just like bailing out they're like screw
that well they're not coming back good
job good job Rob good job no I was okay
so so about the whole Oscar Isaac's
thing so I I do like his face I
immediately recognized it when I saw it
okay but I couldn't remember what he was
in I want to say maybe it was like the
Tutors or The Borges or something like
that that was that was like a Netflix
original but whatever it was like he was
a really good villain like he was a like
he was just like guy who's like kind of
a jerk you know and and he he was really
good in what it was I just cannot
remember off top of my head like it's
driving me nuts I sitting here trying
deal with it trying to remember I can't
remember it's gonna be a horrible
apocalypse see here's here's my qu see
here's here gon be bad well I don't I
mean Days of Future Past wasn't bad no I
mean like and Brian Singer is making it
so it'll be a competently made film apt
pupil was wellmade it was also dumb as
crap but like Brian Singer knows how to
make a picture it just the picture might
be of a cow like it might be something
lame it might be anything um but
yeah yeah I'm I'm on I'm on the fence
about it and I think people are on the
fence about it rightfully so because
you're talking about bringing in like
one of the biggest like the biggest
villain that the Xmen ever faced they
had some like sinu would be a really
cool villain to see but like he he hands
down has to be like the biggest villain
they've ever face just because they they
never successfully stop him they just
hold him off for a little while yeah
well it's like the Juggernaut like you
can never stop him yeah isn't that
like yeah yeah like once once he starts
moving he can't be stopped but but see
with apocalypse it was it was never like
it was never that case like the
Juggernaut was basically like like he
was dumb for the most part yes he was
just a dum the Juggernaut is a Rube yeah
you guys are being mean to the
Juggernaut well no but like that was
like he would just show up like I hate
Charles Xavier and he would just start
like tearing up the Xavier Institute and
then leave like that was
basically I mean like the best I think
the one of the most like accurate and
Well Done portrayals of Juggernaut has
been in the X-Men cartoon during dark
Phoenix Saga when he was just a Rube
used him because he's like he is a great
weapon but he's also such a tool yeah
he's he's not but see with apocalypse it
was never that way like the problem that
I think the fox is going to run into is
apocalypse is not like a one-time
villain like he shows up he does some
stuff and then it's it's like the MCU
with Ultron like how do you introduce a
character that is a recurring character
and a recurring foe Against The Avengers
or the X-Men respectively yeah and then
keep him interesting like that that was
a problem that they have in the comics
like when Lis Simonson and when wall
Simon made him the question was like
what do we do that's why we have the
horsemen like we'll talk about that in
my video about the horsemen but that's
why the horsemen are there the horsemen
are the like I guess the henchmen of
Apocalypse they can constantly go
against the X-Men they can constantly be
defeated but you never run into this
situation of why doesn't apocalypse just
kill the X-Men already more than capable
like why doesn't he just destroy them
like that's like the conundrum we always
get with comic books you always have you
always have the question of where's the
rest of the superheroes in the universe
to a world ending the villain and why
does every villain need to do a
monologue to the point where he loses
when he could just easily snap his
fingers and end the entire universe um
every comic book has that issue and
that's there's something you have to
like look away from well it's also like
apocalypse is basically like a God and
it's like yeah why doesn't he just end
the world already especially since we
have like at least two or three dark
futures is where he does well is it
isn't that like that the explanation
that the like Thanos is the same
question but they explain that Thanos
doesn't do it like at some point it's
explained that he doesn't do it because
he likes the the conflict and the
killing and that's why he doesn't I
always assumed that the reason why
Thanos never ended the world is because
he only had The Infinity Gauntlet the
one time like it's not that he has The
Infinity Gauntlet and he just chooses
not to use it like The Infinity Gauntlet
was that one time he got the gauntlet
and then like I mean it wasn't even a
gauntlet it was his glove yeah it wasn't
like something he went out and found
yeah it's not like the gauntlet exists
as he invented it as a gauntlet and but
he only had it the one time like I think
that's kind of like a big thing to
remember about Thanos is that like
Thanos isn't really like Thanos is cool
but I never really considered him to be
like a big Cosmic badass because like
the one time he had the gauntlet he was
but then after that they easily defeated
him right right it's only now like in
like with infinity and with the movies
and stuff that Thanos is this huge
problem well see here here's the issue
they're doing more with him with
Revelations and stuff like Thanos is be
they're turning him into one but see
here's here's a problem that you have
like you had you had thosa came in with
Jim starling's run so you have basically
everything in the 1980s in the 1990s
with Thanos and Adam Warlock yeah all
right and then Jim Starin left Thanos
and then it just became crap after that
because what what they started try to do
with this character is they try to like
make him like this Uber villain like you
had Marvel the end all right the the mo
the most pitiful ending to a story ever
where Thanos captures a heart of the
universe all right he has absolute power
like no one can stop him and he brings
the entire universe to an end too
there's actually a point in the comics
where it's just Thanos standing in a
void of Blackness and then Adam Warlock
appears and it's like why are you doing
this like there's no real motivation and
and Thanos is like yeah you know what
you're right like there's no real
purpose in living like this so he just
sets it all back like Marvel just wrote
themselves into a corner and didn't know
what to do so funny because that book
like we need to tell people like if they
don't know because the the end books are
14 years old like the the Marvel the end
series was they knew we're never going
to kill Wolverine even though you know
uh but like we're
never stop well because he is gonna come
back but like we all know that because
we're all cynics but like the end was
their way of being like we're never
going to tell the last Hulk story but
wouldn't it be cool if we did and so
they gave it to like definitive writers
and really cool artists and said like
write the last Hulk story Peter David
and Peter David wrote a really crappy
Hulk story and they called like garnis
and they were like tell us the last
Punisher story and Garen tolds a really
crappy Punisher story and then they gave
Paul Jenkins who had just done
Wolverine's origin like maybe a couple
years ago or before that and they said
tell the last Wolverine story and he
gave us a really crappy Wolverine story
and they also did Marvel Universe the
end and I think did was that Starin as
well I don't remember uh I don't think
it was that May was cuz like Starin at
least Would Have Made It wordy and
connected with his other material but I
remember picking up Marvel Marvel the
end and reading it and being oh yeah it
was written by Jim Starin written in
pencil by Jim Starin that sounds about
right but uh there it was such a cool
concept that like they totally dropped
the ball on but in a way they never
could have predicted because they gave
it to the writers who told those awesome
stories and by the way little known fact
if you were reading Spider-Man at the
time I know that I all all roads lead to
Spider-Man in my book but like stazinski
was writing Spider-Man at the time and
he had written Amazing Spider-Man 500
which told you like the last Spider-Man
story kind of like where you see like
Spider-Man's beginning in his end and
his in his end he's like kind of an old
dude and he's wearing like this really
like modified Spider-Man costume and
it's Spider-Man dying and
uh you like I always got the impression
that sosinski was sewing the seeds of a
Spider-Man the end book because they did
like Hulk Wolverine Punisher Marvel like
they did a bunch of the end stories but
they never did a Spider-Man the end book
and I was like where is it when are they
going to do that and it never came out
and then strazinsky left Marvel under
less than amicable terms and I'd always
wondered about that so I tweeted out at
strazinsky one time and I was like did
you ever plan on doing a Spider-Man the
end book like was that what you were
doing with with a 500 and he was like
yes I was that was totally what I was
doing and I'm like yay thank you for
telling me that like now I have little
amazing about technology like literally
you could shoot an email or a or a tweet
to people who have you okay Rob [__] man
there's a there's a moth in my
house thought you were like your roof
was caving in yeah I was like this like
a
store how big is the moth it's blocking
up [__] huge man the gandal
lookig oh my
god um well okay well I guess that's a
good way to say because this is
technically a Q&A and you're going but
anyway I think that's cool so do not fly
down here so
MV would like to know how did he get
unsubscribed from you rob were you
unsubscribing your followers no I wasn't
I wasn't like kicking him out or
anything dude I really really hope this
moth does not fly over
here they're creepy looking man Gabriel
attero says Mr jepetto built
Ultron well because he sings the I got
no strings the Pinocchio song yeah yeah
yeah yeah I saw that um aun mat have we
seen the casting for crossbones in
Captain America 3 I thought it was gonna
be the guy from Captain America 2 yeah
that's what I thought he just mixed it
up it's crossbones from two okay okay I
thought I thought I thought that's what
Marvel established like that guy's going
to be crossbow yeah I was like that' be
kind of weird for them to just pull that
rug out from underneath is at this point
I'm curious so are they going to have
crossbones shoot Captain America and
Captain America 3 probably they're
setting up are they going to have Sharon
because Sharon Carter was the one that
killed him so oh yeah or shot him so I'm
wondering if that's what's gonna happen
was that Sharon Carter was she aging 13
in the second movie okay yeah that's
what I thought she had identifi I think
when she uh when she broken or when she
uh yeah when Nick Fury was shot by Bucky
Barnes she busted
expl um
everyone dances for the
mo smoke Mo are it's not smoke it's
vapor Doran wants you to give it a hug
Rob I would love I'm not giving the damn
thing a hug Man flying around here and
[__] and
it's it's probably
Mothra from God that's exactly it's
gonna it's gonna eat me man this thing
Mr is actually it'll wrap you in a
cocoon of silk and then it will eat you
um I don't think any of us are reading
the current Winter Soldier run NB where
he's the man on the wall I wanted to I
been meaning to but I just kept
forgetting about I wanted to I keep
forgetting it exists I'm lucky that I'm
remembering to pick up freaking Thor the
new Thor series that's the thing we were
gonna do uh Winter Soldier number one on
off the rack but we skipped it for Thor
number one which I kind of regret now
because like Thor one was kind of a dud
but Thor two was really cool yeah um
which by the way tomorrow's episode of
off the rack Thor two oh yeah go ahead
and plug your stuff a little more there
TV little house no problem little house
onl Number One Source comic book
material and reviews that's right that's
right that's right anyway uh yeah so we
don't read but we're not reading
it um has anybody read The Weapon X
Program comic I I saw that actually was
looking at it yesterday it's like it it
takes place in the aftermath of
Wolverine being gone doesn't it yeah
yeah followup I thought it does I
thought it was like the followup to what
they're goingon to do with him being
gone because the the biggest like the
Weapon X Project they had constantly
like tried to capture Wolverine use
Wolverine to create other versions so we
got
like3 the funny thing is like I think
they're doing the same thing they did
with battle for the cowl and Fallen sun
and all like this crap about like who
will inherit the mantle of Wolverine how
about nobody how about w die here's my
question though if they're going to do a
mantle inheriting kind of thing how can
you do it like battle for the cow was
the Batman cow someone will become
Batman what you going to take his
claws well there a bunch of cars with
claws I guess I don't know they do have
a lot the saddest thing with the Fallen
sun was their slogan who will wield The
Shield yeah I'm like are you
kidding so stupid but yeah idea I don't
I don't know I so back on the topic
about apocalypse I don't know how I feel
about this it's a hell of a go back on
topic moment yeah well you know what
don't worry about me so we got we got so
far off that topic it was it was
terrible this is a Q&A Rob we're not
we're not here doing topics
well people okay
so sper how do you feel
about dinosur okay fine we'll answer
questions we can talk about all day if
you want but it just sounds like you
just want to rant about how he's not a
bad bad villain even though he's a
horrible villain who's who is just there
PL device let's have let's have a live
Q&A and a podcast and not answer
questions worst Q&A
ever we have questions coming up okay so
how how does everyone feel about
Star-Lord plus the
dinosaur whatever I like Chris Pratt now
I don't know how I feel about the new
Jurassic Park being about a hybrid crazy
dinosaur I heard it's like a half human
deal no it won't be a half human deal
that was a re that was an idea they
almost did where they literally they did
oh there's concept art you got to look
it up Google like rejected Jurassic Park
concept art and you will find these
amazing drawings uh like by real movie
industry artists of dinosaur men like
literally dinosaur men with like their
bipedal and their dinosaur dudes with
like with like
guns what because they had no idea what
to do it's funny because like the
Jurassic Park people are like I don't
know what to do with the Jurassic Park
franchise how about you send him to the
park and then dinosaurs try to eat oh
God here's a oh wow here's a Darth Vader
a Darth Vader dinosaur somebody made
Darth Vader dinosaur it's pretty amazing
by the way really quick I was just
telling these guys uh before the chat
that I was watching there's a really
really sweet Machinima
series called like epic battles or
something like I can't remember what the
hell it's called but it's like oh super
super power Beatdown and they get like
real independent movie creators with
real special effects and real like cool
uh Prosthetics and stuff and just show
you a argument that we would have on the
weekly poll come to life like Wolverine
versus Batman or uh Green Lantern vers
or uh not Green Lantern uh the Green
Ranger versus some other character I
don't Green Arrow no it's they did uh I
only remember the ones that I oh they
did Master Chief versus Captain America
and the most recent one I saw was Darth
Vader versus Batman and it looks really
cool um you didn't miss anything Ben
buff Ben stuffed okay interesting name
um we're doing a Q&A so any questions
you have go ahead and ask him um yeah I
saw something similar to that with a
digital Cordo just did a video in which
it was like it was Superheroes versus
video game Universe guys cool so it was
like Lor coft Master Chief the Minecraft
guy um Pokemon dude all fight Thor uh
Captain America and uh Wolverine
okay wolver probably killed most of
those people no they took him out almost
immediately they lobed the shield into
his brain and just cut it off
wow that' be the one person want to kill
right off the I would assume that Ash
would just catch Wolverine a Pokeball
they try I they try that you got to
watch it they do try that he throws a
Pokeball at somebody and it's just
like um no I I I have faith in Chris
Pratt Chris Pratt to me is like Ben
Affleck not in terms of his ability to
act I think Ben Affleck's a better actor
but if he gets a good script it'll be
good yeah like like if the if the script
for the movie doesn't suck and that's
the problem like Jurassic Park 3 was
just absolute garbage like that movie
was just I hated it it was the second
one no I like the second I like the
third one more the second one to be
honest yeah same here second one has
them going to the second one's the one
where they go to New York and crap and
it's like a Godzilla thing isn't it uh
that is
Godzilla Godzilla reboot with with
Matthew brri that was a horrible movie
in itself where that was a ripoff of
Jurassic Park because then like Godzilla
gives birth to freaking Raptors and it's
really dumb okay here's a good here's an
actual good question um do you guys have
any plans to do reviews of non-marvel
and DC Comics I'm G I'm gonna let Marvel
explained go first on that um well as
you guys know like I launched a DC
explain Channel um that I haven't done
anything with yet I haven't uploaded
anything to it yet by the way if anybody
in the chat is good with like Graphics
like email me Rob ATM marvel.com with
your ideas for DC exlain Graphics for my
channel um I may Branch out but at this
point like with the direction
everything's going in and the whole um
like Age of Apocalypse thing that was
going to take us a long time to finish
like it'll be a little while before I
Branch into that but will I I mean I
don't see why not I mean I think that
some of those Indie Comics have a lot of
potential in terms of of like the
stories they can tell and the characters
in them that a lot of people just don't
know about so I think it'd be kind of
cool to go back and and Branch out into
that stuff I
mean I don't know cool probably you you
already do Indie stuff over at TV little
house don't you we do yeah um we're
we're kind of moving away from it a
little bit but like I would eventually
we will uh we will be doing something a
little bit more Indie focused um but we
do like to mix it up on off the rack uh
the we had we did some indie books on
back issues in the beginning like we did
spawn and gen 13 um I I think they may
have found their day but back when we
started those were like those were death
like nobody want nobody cared about gen
13 um but people remember and I I think
I think they'll I think those episodes
found Their audience and I think if we
did like more Main
independent books like if we did bone I
think it would be good I think if we did
like Savage
dragon witches I don't well we we could
never we do we did witches on uh on off
the rack I don't think we could ever do
a back issues on anything like that
though well I'm like okay so it's really
scary right
and and then they're just like oh that's
really uncomfortable yeah and then they
pull it through the tree and they're
like what and then it comes out of her
neck and it's just like that's not
really the format so I don't think
people really dig it I mean it's it's
like I would love the idea of doing like
other doing like smaller stuff in comics
like doing doing like like Indie stuff
but but like I said like this like this
Age of Apocalypse thing is a huge
undertaking like we got to talk about
like Gene nation and Factor 3 and stuff
like that like Factor 3 was like this
Uncanny X-Men like like goofy no maybe
it was X-Men volume two anyway it was
they appeared sometime between issue
number 25 and 30 and and they were just
kind of like man you know whatever it
was kind of stupid but like that kind of
some of the stuff we got to talk about
but I mean I think the idea of ranching
out into any is a really cool idea
because I think a lot of people like
they're they're like Marvel Comics like
they're curious about it but they just
don't know what to do so I mean even I'm
curious about a lot of the Indie Comics
people talk about yeah so uh velvet's
really good by the way which is Velvet
we tried it we've tried it over at uh
we've done the same thing you have with
s where we try a little bit and actually
I really love the response the Indie
book of stor shows gets where we discuss
three or four Indie books of the week um
but it doesn't get a lot of views at all
which makes it kind of difficult to
rationalize putting up like I love it
gets more comments than everything else
in great better discussion oh yeah um
but I also really enjoy Indie books uh
I've been talking to a lot of Indie
books guys I'm going to probably start
doing some Walking Dead very starting in
the New Year I'm going to start putting
in some more Indie book stuff so like
yeah Indie books that aren't really
Indie you know they're more they're more
high-profile Indie books yeah exact more
more high-profile ones the ones that are
doing well I'll probably do some know
universes on them maybe do some
condensed story lines um I thought about
doing witches but I don't know how it's
it's kind of like trying to tell the
story of like you know a versus book
like okay they they fought and lots of
blood
scary it was really scary and then I
freaked out like and then I had to turn
the lights on and then yeah exactly um
the the you know and like this could be
appropriate let's let's throw it out
there but like I don't know about like
Benny we We have dealt with uh reviewing
and talking about Indie books I have
received almost zero support from Indie
creators in promoting their books we've
gotten more support from Marvel and DC
who you would think would ignore us
right and they don't need our help like
they s us trailers and No One's Gonna
like yeah at the end of the day they're
gonna buy a Marvel book but like they
don't need us to sell Spiderwoman but um
yeah like for whatever reason like will
we did we did uh trees we did um the
judge Anderson from uh 200 ad press like
we did a lot of independent books but
higher profile stuff and zero support
from the creators themselves which kind
of kills me because like 2,000 purchases
of an independent book is the difference
between a A-list independent title and
the and total obscurity like if 2,000
people bought one copy of witch not
witches because it's Scott Snider but
like low Low's a great example because
low is a great book but no one's like
yeah if 2,000 people bought low low
would like the creator of low would
freak the hell out 2,000 people might
watch an episode of one of us doing anep
a review of low the creator of low has
no interest in helping us promote that
book right not because I mean I I mean
he's 100% right like we we do this stuff
to get your guys responses but yeah
there's more like we don't do Indie book
stuff so we put up something Indie books
like people want to see Marvel and DC so
it needs to gain some kind of traction
in the Indie book Market kind of a deal
for the video to even do very well and
actually do its purpose which is to help
promote the Indie book now like I did
try doing a Stephen Frank Silver which
Rob also interviewed over here at Marvel
explain which is Awesome by the way
great interview yeah one of the few guys
that are Indie book creators that was
all for talking to us and I loved his
book I'm reading his book I know quite a
few people that have picked up his book
based upon those interviews and stuff
like that so we want to do it but it's
hard to do it when they don't want us to
do it and since there's not much of a a
market for it if the creator doesn't
want us to do it the viewers really
don't want to watch it that much we run
into a boat of now we're doing the Indie
book stuff for ourselves which as much
as I like to do I can go do more Green
Lantern yeah I mean the other thing is
like for me I feel like it's really
essential to talk about independent
books and I that's why I'll never stop
in some way but I think what we'll do is
we'll take I'm going to take the
independent books take them off of off
the rack and then give them maybe to
Tiffany and she'll do like an
independent series but like the the fact
is independent books need to be sold
they need to be re read and they need to
be successful because not only are they
good not all of them by the way but not
only are independent Comics interesting
and giving you new ideas they're also
bringing new blood into the industry
itself and you need it and you can't
have or rather it's not the best move
for indie or for new creators to cut
their teeth on a top tier title like
okay you could give a new writer or a
new artist moonnight or speedball or
Nighthawk or uh yeah or Nighthawk like
and give them their own title uh and see
them learn how to you know learn the
ropes or break new ground with those t
with those characters that like no one
really cares if you do anything
interesting or new with them but I think
it's better for the industry to have new
creators do something fresh original and
interesting and present to the you know
to the populace and say hey like read
this and have them broaden their
Horizons but also like learn
storytelling and then they take lessons
they learned and then apply them to the
top tier tit like to top tier books um I
think that's the way to do it because
like that's where you got Warren Ellis
that's where you got Brian Michael
bendes that's where you got uh Paul
Jenkins like that's where you get the
people who are now architects of the big
two like that's where Scott SN came from
like that that's where they came from is
independent books and you need those
books to succeed and the problem is when
you sell when you don't buy them like
that they're going to stop making them
well more so than that like you have a
lot of of former like big- time writers
in Marvel yeah that or DC that are
branching off and so you you have like
huge writers that left and now they're
doing Indie titles yeah and so you have
like all kinds of of a mishmash of of
guys over there doing Indie comics and
and it was always kind of ironic to me
that a person who was aspiring to like
make their comic popular wouldn't accept
somebody reaching out and saying hey
look like like we can really like we can
try to help even if it's not like a huge
thing even if not like you're going to
explode into popularity yeah like we we
you know we'll get you some some
attention but I think with with in those
instances I think people look at it and
they say like either you're going to
help me just like hu like hit the
mainstream huge and be like the next big
writer for Marvel or DC or just don't
worry about it yeah and so it's like all
right whatever yeah so I think I think
we've g a pretty crazy tangent to that
question but the the of the matter is is
Andy are a weird thing where the
creators don't care that we do them and
you guys don't want to watch them half
the time so that's why it's an iffy
thing for us to go into because as much
as we enjoy the Indie books we still
need to maintain content on the channel
that people want to watch that's just
simple it um I mean I the channels are
not tiny channels so we don't we don't
and that that that's a problem that I've
run into where I want to go do a
different story but we we we're kind of
locked into what is expected to an
extent yeah you know like I I've gone a
couple weeks before where I'm like oh I
really want to tell this story because
this one's epic and I'm all excited
about this but there's these two other
stories over here that you guys are
waiting for conclusions to that I got to
go tell first so yeah um and that that's
yeah man you're not a you're not Chris
Claremont man you don't leave plotting
was just hanging speak which really
quick let's just let me just connect I
got a list of questions but go ahead let
me just connect really quick Chris
claramont wrote X-Men the end and it was
a series that would never end and it was
I think it was five to 10 books per Saga
and there were three sagas wow you got
to read that by the way Marvel explain
you got to do X-Men the end I mean
that's do Xmen in the end do it right
now take a break from Age of Apocalypse
I mean I know of it I've just never read
it I know you gotta read it man because
it's Chris claramont ending the X-Men
yeah which I would love to see oh it's
awesome anyway let's go to the questions
buff Ben stuffed asked for me what was
my favorite episode of the current Flash
show I liked the fourth one uh where he
learned how to run up the walls and run
on water thought that was pretty cool to
see two of his powers develop in the
same episode followed shortly by the
fifth episode where he learned the Super
Sonic punch um not much more to go on
that CU I don't think either one of you
guys even watching that show nope can't
wait for the next episode which I think
is today actually but anyway um uh then
we have a question for I'm assuming why
explain because it's a Marvel Centric
question how would they bring Howard the
Duck into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
if they would add him into a main story
what needs to be done to make that work
and since you're the only one of us that
knows anything about Howard the Duck
yeah God I hate Howard the Duck um he's
getting a new book I
know and I'm I'm gonna I'm never gonna
buy it no um I don't know I mean if
they're talking if okay let's say for
example that that Kevin fagy said okay
let's bring in like Marvel or let's
bring in Howard the Duck into the MC
like make him more than just a character
that shows up at the end of the credits
yeah I mean you've already got a basis
for that they can just build off of
Rocket Raccoon Rocket Raccoon as they
explained it is the product of genetic
engineering and experimentation um they
with Doctor Strange they could explain
that they could say he's the result of
just somebody manipulating magic and
just turned a bipedal duck into a guy
that walks and talks and drinks alcohol
and smoke cigars I don't know I mean
they could do it a multitud different
ways they could stick with the Marvel
Comics version and say just came from an
alternate reality where everybody's
Ducks there's Duckman I mean yeah
there's Duckman I mean I miss dark duck
over there also
Nock oh is Disney so yes duck is now in
there I really want to see that I want
to see I want to see a movie with Howard
the Duck and like his arch nemesis
Darkwing like that would be amazing like
right Darkwing just shows up oh since we
this kind of goes back to what you guys
are just talking about what do you feel
about the the future of the
Xmen man I don't know I don't know the
X-Men the X-Men have lost their way I
like the all new X-Men but that pretty
much has nothing to do with the original
X-Men that we all know in
love here's here's a problem that I
think Marvel has with the X-Men I think
obviously with Fox having the rights to
the X-Men Marvel's doing the same thing
with them that they are with like
Fantastic Four where they're just kind
of relegating them and giving them
crappy stories but even then like even
before that even before this came a
thing where Marvel was like you know
what let's just like basically screw
over all the characters that we don't
own in the movies in the comments or in
the comics let's just like you know
whatever segue him throw him in the back
Shuffle him who cares but
um but
uh I would say wow you seem like already
defeated you haven't really talked about
it no no no no no I got a I got I got a
text message I got a text message here's
the problem with the X-Men all right and
and and pardon me because I might go on
a little bit of a r here here's the
problem with the X-Men all right we
talked about this in X-Men explain
Stanley and Jack Kirby made the X-Men
the X-Men floundered people just didn't
really care about it too much Chris
Claremont came back revital Iz the X-Men
did it for 17 years and made the X-Men
cool Claremont leaves Jim Lee makes the
X-Men cool for like a year and then Jim
Lee leaves yeah Jim Lee's gone I mean
X-Men X-Men volume two issue number one
is the highest selling comic of all time
yeah so it's it's a huge deal well for
for the record Jim Lee kind of went to a
really good career at image which then
led into pretty much like co-running DC
so oh I know I know I'm not I don't
think he made a stupid decision at
all he's currently the biggest guy at DC
and artist wise by the way yeah yeah his
without Jim Le doing X-Men Jim Lee has
no career because the wild cats are the
X-Men like look at wild cats and then
tell me that isn't what he drew during
the 90s X-Men era I've heard that but
but be that be that as it may like after
Jim Lee and Chris Claremont left Marvel
just didn't know what to do with the
X-Men I mean you you had like Marvel see
here's the problem that Marvel had you
had the mutant Massacre event which was
huge the it was it was the biggest
crossover the Marvel ever that people
consider Marvel ever had with the uh the
X-Men related titles the first one never
saw anything like it before Marvel saw
the popularity and said okay let's just
start doing Xmen related crossovers
Extinction agenda fatal attractions so
on and so forth and it just kept going
that way they were good but it just kept
going that way the problem is crossovers
it's like we talked about last time
crossovers became too huge of a thing Y
and it got to a point where the X-Men
lost their identity where what it was
that made the X-Men cool began to go
away the split-offs the Splinter the
Splinter groups you know Generation X or
Gene Nation from the morlocks or stuff
like that they stopped being interesting
and so it got to a point where Marvel
had this group of mutants and the
question is like what what do you do
with them like how often can we really
have the X-Men fighting the Friends of
Humanity yeah how often yeah like how
often can we really have the X-Men just
struggling to go against because here's
here's the issue the X-Men were huge
back in the day when like racial issues
were a big thing and it's kind of a big
thing now but not so much anymore like
it's you know with the exception of
things of what's going on in Missouri
like it's not a constantly thrust in
your face kind of thing and so like J
opposing X-Men and their struggleing
Against Humanity with like racial
struggles in the United States is just
not a thing anymore and so like Marvel's
just doesn't know what to do with their
character they don't know what to do
with the X-Men I don't think and they're
just kind of throwing them in these
situations and they're like well let's
cross over the Avengers and the X-Men
with X-Men versus Avengers you know and
and it's just like okay and and that's
it you know they I think they try to
make it cool every once in a while but
honestly I think Marvel just doesn't
really care about the X-Men that much at
the moment which is why you see them
focusing on so many other things like
moonight and so on and so I think the
biggest problem with the X-Men is
they've tried to make other X-Men
prominent by doing things like shuffling
Cyclops off to jail because he killed
Professor X getting rid of Professor X
removing Wolverine from the core X-men
group and making him go kill himself you
know like a lot of the core people just
aren't there anymore I mean that's
proven by the fact that the current
genan gry schools I think the original
cast has Bobby Drake and Hank left like
out of The Originals that's it yeah yeah
so which I mean to a degree is to be
expected but Marvel experimented that
but experimented with the idea of like
bringing in new Xmen including new Xmen
and so on but I think in all honesty as
much as I love the story do you know
what I think I think Marvel shot
themselves in the foot with the house of
him like I think they screwed up with
the house of him I loved the story I
loved the element and I think that what
Marvel wanted to do with the House of M
and I think like Bendis explicitly
explained this they said that what they
wanted to do is they wanted to have a
clean slate they basically wanted to
like take it to back to the day when
Claremont first took over the X-Men yeah
like they just started too many what was
there like 3,000 X-Men at that point or
something yeah there were there were
thousands and thousands of of X not to
mention any of the other teams and all
the other I mean you had like Freedom
Force back in the day in the 1990s you
had all kinds of stuff going on also
they had they had unnamed mutants living
in like mtown or like in on their own
countries like you had mutants that you
didn't even you haven't even introduced
yet so yeah the place is you had guys
like like Mr M like this this super
obscure guy that could work reality and
he just lived in an apartment in in am
toown in mutant town and just like
worked on electronics yeah and fixed
people's stuff like that that's it the
guy was like a handyman guy could warp
reality and he was a handyman like yeah
and also like how does how does a a
person who's naturally born ability to
warp reality translate into racial
inequality yeah that's that's the
problem that's the issue that you have
how do you make the X-Men interesting
yeah all the interesting stories of all
the X-Men have long since been gone the
other thing that they've that I've found
with people who don't necessarily read
them or who who are looking to jump in
they're like so okay I the people have a
problem with the X-Men because they're
born different they're born with the
ability to like fly and shoot fire out
of their eyes but like but at the end of
the day it's because they're born with
powers why don't they have such a
problem with
Daredevil hm like why don't they why
don't they all hate Captain America and
Thor and it's
like I really can't answer that because
like because because they got their
powers by accident you they can't help
that like that's an that was you know
well yes it's really flimsy I think the
the argument as simple as this and it
goes down to the to the the the racial
equality and all that stuff but like the
mutants are the next Evolution you know
I mean the whole point is they're
different be but because were born that
way they're the next level they're
completely by definition different from
us while Captain America did get his
powers elsewhere Daredevil got his
powers elsewhere you know the house of
them Spider-Man was portrayed as a
mutant that's a you know so well he was
portrayed he was pretending to be a
mutant right really cool yeah that that
minseries by the way and it sucks
because Mark Wade wrote it so it should
be great but it's
like yeah I mean it's it's it's funny
when you look at the history of the
X-Men in Marvel Comics because you just
you see like this huge Spike and then
you see this kind of trend off Marvel
had a really good opportunity to
revitalized interest in the X-Men and
they screwed it up Marvel had that
interest with Hope Summers when Marvel
first introduced Hope Summers the
question was is she G to be good or is
she gonna be bad is she going to be the
Catalyst for Bishop's future or is she
gonna actually like help save lives and
instead they were just kind of like
Phoenix for is coming back Avengers
versus X-men done and done and it was
like okay
like way to totally screw up when we
we've talked about uh when we talked
about the end of X-Men versus Avengers
people were like so what happens with
hope and I'm like not much yeah that's
it she's just an inh care that nobody
understands yeah isn't she just hanging
out in Utopia now like she doesn't she
hasn't been a part of nothing since then
she she is like she's like Jubilee from
the 90s with more power like that's the
best way I never did anything
interesting yeah that's true I I have a
question though cuz this is from me to
you guys I like like Hope's costume but
where does like superheroes get off
going like I want a costume and I want
it to look ripped up and torn like I'm
out of the Dune show oh it's the uh it's
that derite that derite uh yeah that
fashion style man derite I understand
that with hope like she has like a
normal costume and like this Shaw that's
torn and RI maybe it's like a Remnant
maybe it's like maybe it's like
Superman's capee and it's like a it's
the blanket the cable wrapped her in
when she was a baby that's why I store
her up yeah uh
it's just it's crazy I don't know so
you're saying that the X-Men were
written for a demographic that doesn't
really exist anymore pretty much the
X-Men the X-Men were founded in a time
and like enhanced in a time that people
can't relate to anymore yeah and so
marel just doesn't know what to do with
them anymore no or at least they don't
know how to make them more relatable
yeah that's true and I think they're
still stuck in the bind of the more
popular that they make the X-Men the
more money they make for Fox the more
the less chance Fox is going to give
them back X X-Men yeah so it's kind of
like a weird thing where they don't
really want to make the X-Men completely
irrev but at the same time if you do too
much of them you're gonna promote Fox's
movie and you're never going to get the
license back yeah and Wolverine makes
money yeah yeah Wolverine and don't
don't get me wrong man like the Marvel
brass know how to make a story if Marvel
goes to Brian Michael Bendis and they
say you're not doing anything but
focusing on the X-Men and solely the
X-Men yeah for the next like two years
Make It Count I guarantee you Brian
Michael Bennis is make a fantastic
series of X he's doing that now he wrote
all new he's writing all new Xmen no no
no no no I'm talking I'm not talking
about Ultimate Marvel I'm not talking I
mean all new X-Men is 616 Marvel like
that's they're awesome I thought I
thought they got shunted off to that
book is still going yeah no they they
got shut off to the Marvel Ultimate
Universe but they didn't get put there
as like this is where they permanently
are they they got warped over there with
a oh no how do we get here and how do we
get back
that he actually he quit he was like I'm
done with Avengers I want to do X-Men
now and Marvel's like you're it's yours
and he's like I don't really know what
I'm doing yeah just did all I thought I
thought they sent him see I haven't kept
up with all new X I have all new X I
just haven't kept up with I quit it's
boring as
hell it's it's gone really downhill ever
since the uh uh the original sin when
they did the will they just had like
like 10 filler issues same problem he
had with with Guardians of the Galaxy
where you just had to put a whole bunch
of filler issues in to fill it out yeah
that was I mean like the tri gr was fun
but like who cares my problem with the
tri of Gan gray is that it was awesome
but the fact is it was one book
stretched into six with a lot of just
sitting in chairs going I don't know why
they want to kidnap you Gan gray have
they do they know that you're a new
person oh my God they do know what are
they doing that's pretty much that was
it for yeah I hated the trial of Jean
Gray oh my God Gan gray like you're Jean
Gray from a different dimension and like
a younger version right yes I am okay
you have the ability to possess a
phoenix for right yes I are you the same
Jee gray that died before no well you
could be so we're just going to put you
on trial Al never mind the fact they
killed the Phoenix yeah I was like this
is dumb yeah what is your mug there Rob
what is on your mug oh God this is
WrestleMania
30 yeah man sweet yeah it was exciting
um okay yeah uh I I don't know if my
chat's broken or we're not getting any
questions no we're not getting any more
questions oh yeah I guess that's it all
right well I guess we'll see you guys
next week and people people don't care
anymore people like whatever don't care
yeah they all left you guys are already
boring you're boring so somebody asked a
question have we ever thought about
writing our own comic book oh s does it
yeah yeah but I mean like the three of
us creating a comic doing our own book
what the YouTube Avengers book what
while trying to make videos aun tsunami
hit they use their powers of
interrupting of talking in a s sexy
voice and of gathering friends to
combine their efforts into
I mean like my okay if I made a comic
book like if somebody made a comic book
about me like it would suck and you want
to know why because it would be like it
would be like me getting up at like 8
o'clock in the morning and then like
sitting down in front of my computer and
then just like reading comics and like
verifying my information's right talking
to Benny every once in a while I'm here
stopping yeah stopping and getting on
Facebook you know like dying over here
I'm having a crash yeah like drinking
some coffee and just kind of like all
right you know and
then you know like going to get some
food maybe and this the question excting
you're boring me already so this
question is gonna lead to a discussion I
know it will we're gon so I'm going to
set aside 10 minutes while they give us
more questions all right um what do we
think about the Dr droom as a internet
troll troll
blogger God okay I was I was I was like
okay I'm going to give Fox the benefit
of the the doubt or Warner Brothers
whoever owns the rights to the Fantastic
Four in the films I'm going to give him
the benefit of the doubt I'm going to I
I sat down and I said okay we had the
original Fantastic 4 movie and I was
like H movie was kind of crappy but you
know they could segue into something
better and then we got Rise of the
Silver Surfer which was absolute trash Y
and I was like okay maybe they've
learned maybe they've learned that like
they suck with what they've done so far
maybe they like fired the the
screenwriter and they said like you suck
at making movies you suck
yeah like they said like let's sit down
let's let's actually think about making
a good movie so I said okay like this
this is going to be decent like we're
going to have the ultimate version of
Johnny Storm I don't know why but you
know like it's gonna be it's GNA be
decent I don't the interracial stuff
like having like RAC yeah I don't I
don't care I was like that's that's cool
like they be more Progressive like
they've got Michael B Jordan he was
really good in chronicle so I'm like all
right we're gonna get some pretty cool
stuff which also something a lot of
people don't know he had a really cool
he was a really cool episode of House
back in the day where he was uh blind I
think and then he faced the choice of
being blind and deaf so it was a really
cool concept but um anyway then they
come out and they say that basically Dr
Doom is going to be a kid that sits at
home hates his life and just writes a
bunch of crappy things on the internet I
hate I threw my hands in the air and I
said I give
up you know you know what this strikes
me this strikes me as them trying to
Nolan up the Fantastic for yeah trying
to realistically well it would have make
sense for him to be the ruler of a
Nation the UN would have stepped in a
while ago so let's make him an Internet
troll if that is their logic it it's
like they're doing it just to piss
people off like I don't know if if that
is if that's their answer if if that's
what they said they said well we want to
make this realistic you've got a man
that can stretch his body to virtually
any length all right you've got a woman
that can make herself invisible and make
force fields she has such a finite
control over her abilities that she can
shut down blood going to a portion of a
person's brain and knock them out yeah
all right you've got a guy that can set
himself on fire that can reach the
temperature of an exploding Sun an
exploding Sun yeah that's n all right
you've got you've got a guy made of
rock and a guy made of rocks and a guy
made of rocks the guy is a giant boulder
all right have they said what they're
going to do with him are they doing
anything weird with uh he looks like the
thing he's just gonna be he's mostly CG
okay yeah but they want to turn around
and make this like grounded it's a comic
book movie man how realistic could it
really be yeah I mean it like with see
here's here's a problem people have like
people look at Christopher Nolan and
they say he had an awesome idea and
making the series realistic it's a
billionaire yeah he can to do that stff
yeah he could afford to do that stuff
because he's just got so much money I
guarantee you if Bill Gates really
wanted to he could do what Batman's
doing he'd die really fast but he could
do yeah he could do what Batman's doing
he could to do that okay I'm just going
to buy like military grade Parts I'm
going to buy military grade vehicles
that they've disregarded they have no
real need for so I can probably buy it
really cheap yeah I mean like they could
afford to do that like like you can't do
that when you have characters that have
exotic powers that come out of their
hands like you can't do that but no no
he's not actually stretching it's
robotic stretching
Powers not but that's uh yeah no one
goes to see a Fantastic Four movie or a
Marvel even a Marvel Comics movie to see
something grounded in realism they want
a little bit of realism and a lot of
imagination that's what they want the uh
the only good part of it is that it will
tank and it and then Marvel will get it
back that's that's the that's what I'm
hoping for I'm hoping this is Fox you
know what the hell with it just fail
like that I needed to fail like the my
reaction to Dr Doom being an Internet
troll nerd is like good [__] it up big
time like please so that we can just
have it back because clearly like like
fox said no to a deal Marvel offered
them which prolongs the ability for
Galactus to show up which prevents us
from being able to see the Silver Surfer
arrive which keeps us from having Dr
Doom fight Iron Man like fine fail we'll
go see doctor strange we go see Captain
Marvel we'll go see that awesome
infinity War crossover movie and then
we'll have the Fantastic forb back
that's that's that's what I that's what
I want to see I want to see
I want to see Infinity War part two come
to an end I want to see the credits
rolling all right and then I want to see
a 30C clip and I want to see like Reed
Richards I want to see Reed Richards
just just working in his laboratory he
didn't even have to be doing anything
specific just a man with with dark hair
and white stripes along his head just
like like furiously typing away and like
all like all he does like look up at the
screen you know like look up at his
computer screen just keep on typing you
know and like write an equation down and
I would be over the moon oh here it is
right it's a pushing it's a it's a pull
out from the back of his head right and
you're just like he's in a lab coat you
don't really know who it is but he's at
the this crazy amazing lab like it it
looks like a computer station and it
pulls back and you see it's a dude in a
lab coat sitting in a work chair and
you're like okay but it pulls back more
and it gets wider and wider and you see
his lab table just keeps going over and
over and over like it just goes big
bigger and bigger and you're like that's
a big lab table and then right when it's
at its widest he reaches over and gets
yes yes and then brings it back so you
don't have to cast him you know it could
be you're like there he is he's in the
movie do it and then later they cast him
so you're already planning the 30 second
bumper that probably will never happen
yeah or will like maybe I hope you know
what negativity is not needed here Benny
got to stay positive um the uh we had a
guy comment about nerd sync Productions
ever bring on the podcast we are in
talks with him just so you guys know uh
we've been talking with him he may join
us he may not uh we don't know kind of
depends on him but if you want him to
show up go to his videos and be like the
weekly pull sent me they're so much
better than you no if you ever want to
see anybody appear on this show the best
way to do it is to ask the people you
want to see on this show yeah to be on
the show like tell them to go to Marvel
explain go to comic story and go to TV
little house and say I want to be there
and have them show up so you just go to
their channels and leave comments hey I
want you on the weekly poll have you
considered talking to Rob yeah tweeted
them that works too
um uh where is Marvel on colel politics
know for current events and
uh no we're not doing Ferguson or
politics Marvel Marvel is known for
tracking current events like especially
in their politics but here's a problem
that was largely Fantastic Four stuff
Fantastic 4 followed current trends
everybody else has kind of fought
amongst themselves because of Fantastic
4 are
non-existent like yeah they Marvel's not
basically doing that uh yes that is
actually a good question buff been
stuffed asked will we ever see the
followup to the end of the book
Spiderman buff B hold on is it buff been
stuffed
yeah that's from that's from that's from
uh he said you would know that's from
2001 when uh the WWF bought WC he said
you would know it yeah nice um yeah the
Spider-Man has Peter Parker Googling
Miles Morales and he's shocked to see
what Miles Morales is in our universe
the 616 Universe um I would love to see
a conclusion of that because that was
what like three years ago yeah I was
like oh this going to be great we're
going to see but oh we haven't seen [__]
no apparently Bendis has said that he is
going to do a sequel and it will
directly address that issue I hope so I
was kind of hoping spiderverse would
maybe touch on it finally yeah it's
not they're going to meet up again you
think he' be like oh hey did they
already met they literally already met
in spiderverse and he's just like miles
let's go yeah he's like miles what's
going on man by the way you're a serial
killer of My Universe anyway let's go
yeah he does not say that that'd be
amazing
yeah um
there's one thing Disney does right
fantastic movies yes
H as a buff the stuff said to you had
some questions that were earlier but let
me I'm trying to find him that's why I'm
just kind of reading stuff right now um
do you think DC will create a DC cinema
cinema to handle their movies whom from
DC a filmmaker or two would you
recommend them running it uh DC's just
doing it all wrong so I don't know yep
everything they're doing is wrong like
here's what here's what I I still want
to know why they aren't tying the TV
Universe into the
move it's a Multiverse Benny [__] it
give it get I know we we could be we DC
could easily be the goddamn Kings of the
movie TV they've got three show we got
two right now we have a third one
[__] coming out that's already tied
in we have Constantine who kind of kind
of isn't canceled already yeah
Constantine got canceled oh they the TV
show got canel they they halted
production ah okay well we still got
three we still got been out for like a
month I know we got we still got Arrow
we got Flash and we still have the
already pretty much cast it out
Supergirl show you you've already got it
establ you could you could throw away
all your previous crap throw it all away
I don't care go with those three shows
and do the new Cinematic Universe
combine the freaking two of them if you
don't want Grant Gustin to be your flash
just keep the flash in the goddamn
costume and have him run the freak
around no one would ever know yeah all
right here's here's what I want to see
in in like with a DC Cinematic
Universe I love the Marvel C Universe I
love it it's it's amazing it's awesome
but the Marvel Cinematic Universe is is
high-profile explosions lights glitter
you know all that kind of cool stuff I
want to see a DC Cinematic Universe I
want to see tone down I want to see dark
I want to see drama I want to see
Christopher Nolan DC like movies imagine
if Christopher Nolan that's what they're
doing Superman yeah yeah yeah no no but
I'm saying imagine if Christopher Nolan
had made like if he was the one actually
that wrote and directed Superman the
same way that he had done the Dark
Knight could you imagine how awesome of
a story that would be could you could
you imagine could you imagine
Christopher Nolan trying to make
Superman realistic no no no no no no he
doesn't need to be realistic like if if
Christopher Nolan stuck because here's a
problem that you had when when you go
back and you watch the Man of Steel you
see Christopher Nolan in there for the
first half of the movie everything that
went on with Krypton then when when
Superman gets to Earth everything after
that is all Zack Snider like that's
that's when you see the difference like
that portion of the movie when you're
you're talking about Krypton and
everything that's going on and stuff
like that that was like the best part of
the movie because you you were focusing
on the actual people like them as actual
people like you're you're you're
focusing on Russell Crowe with the fact
that he's basically saying like there's
nothing we can do now like it's too late
you're talking about Michael Shannon
who's like my sole job here is to keep
this place protected you guys have
screwed it up you know like while you
guys sit around debating all the time
like things are getting worse and worse
and we've literally got less than a day
before this planet blows up I mean
you've you know it was it was really
really cool and that's what I loved
about it like a Christopher Nolan
staying true to the roots of Superman
but giving Superman a darker story I
think in in like in the movies would be
fantastic like I would love that that
that's your problem right there is it
Superman isn't a dark story Superman is
not a dark story Superman is hope they
went as dark as they could possibly go
and I think they kind of cross the line
a little there I mean the whole message
of Hope is still there but I don't need
to see a sad and emo super running up to
the shore stealing some clothes cuz he
doesn't know what to do you know
everything about man of I don't want to
see an Emos Superman no but you did like
everything about Man of Steel is bad and
wrong oh I don't think so everything I
loved it they they could
there's people know the story of Jesus
they know the story of Moses and they
know the story of Superman okay Superman
did you just put Superman on par with
Jesus and Moses pretty much that's
exactly what he said yeah Jesus is
religious figure yeah Superman is a
religious figure like not in a way where
people worship him but like he is a myth
that is used to inspire people to be the
best they can be that's Jesus like if
you don't believe in it you know it's a
story that references that kind of thing
Superman's origin
is so simple and so beautiful in its
Simplicity that it is so stupid that
they needed to complicate it and add new
[__] that that that has no bearing on
the story or on the character like we
need to establish that the kryptonians
select your birth and you like it's the
first natural birth in ever in forever
and like the Codex of our own people is
infused in you and like that's so stupid
and so complicated and needless like
doomed doomed
Planet kindly couple Superman that's all
you need you don't need all this garbage
rides dragons and
like that was pretty awesome him riding
a dragon no it's not I thought it was it
was like you want to watch someone ride
a dragon go watch dragonart but I'm
watching a movie where a guy has a cape
on and he flies I don't need a dragon I
have Superman like we but what if you
had Superman and a dragon then you have
a complicated pile of crap called Man of
Steel what if he what if he rides a
dragon and names it crypto and we don't
why would he ride a dragon he can fly
because why wouldn't you ride a dragon
if you had one because I can fly it
would be a hindrance but wouldn't you
eventually get tired of flying no yeah I
would see Rob I would never get tired of
flying get like you know what like I'm
I'm bored of flying like I just want to
ride his I mean Superman Superman dude
you're you're talking about you're
talking about a story where Superman
would be riding a dragon like imagine
that like you've got Lex Luther like
wreaking havoc in Metropolis Superman
rides in on a fire breathing dragon
that's not called Superman then that's
called something else I think it's good
enough good enough that's something else
that's that's called Transformers
4 no no that was on a T-Rex get your get
your mythological creatures yeah cuz
T-Rex is not mythological that's proven
by jassic Park uh all right a dragon but
like it's not so Rob whatever happened
to the moth I imagine it eating a
sandwich yeah did you kill it or smoke
it out man really somebody really had to
say that [__] I forgot about it
whatever it is now whever it VAP it out
I didn't Vape it out wherever it is now
like it's this room is so filled with
Vape right now it's so F I can see you
like fish boxed yourself yeah Fishbowl
I'm V boxing inside my own I I have no
idea what that moth is and I'm not going
to worry about it because screw that
moth um Hawkeye and green arrow would be
an amazing Marvel DC crossover story yes
I agree Avengers versus X-men or
Avengers versus JLA you see that and it
is great it's as great as you imagine it
s is a Superman Superman fundamentalist
yes um how how to train your Kryptonian
it should be a movie that we get
uh I don't see any you see any Cameron
go back about an hour and you'll hear us
talking about apocalypse yeah yeah
Cameron was like have you guys talked
about
Isaac Oscar Isaac is apocalypse T Little
House Goes Ham for Superman
Dam so yeah actually you know what I'm
going to ask you guys a question real
quick so the weekly pool website's going
to have some unique content that goes on
to it one of the shows we thought would
be a great thing to do is just set s up
on a topic and let him rant yeah I do I
do get set off by a few things funny
when happens um it's it's really
hilarious uh is that something you guys
would enjoy watching a full 20-minute
show of s doing what he just
did I don't know if anybody would want
to watch the 20 minutes of that but five
okay so um so somebody asked a question
is Marvel Now like DC's New 52 um all
right this will be a question it'll be
answered by both me and and Ben and sty
because I know about Marvel now but they
know I have two videos explaining them
but I can say I can take it briefly what
they both are actually I can make it
quick the
new2 and and I'm trying to expand my DC
knowledge so I'm gonna explain this to
make sure you explain New 52 I'll
explain marble now well I'm yeah I'm
trying to make sure that that well as a
quick synopsis of new52 new52 as I
understand it it's just a total reboot
of like DC's Universe ding is that
correct okay it's a total reboot of
everything so you don't even need to go
back and read any of the old stuff you
can just start with new 52 and like all
the Back stories are explained all the
origins are explained and and the whole
nine yards there's a few lanter yeah no
there's a few of them like Batman and
Green Lantern that are still continuing
but they try to give them a fresh enough
reboot that you don't need to go read
them if you really want to okay um
Marvel Now is not a reboot Marvel Now is
basically Marvel going back and saying
you don't have to read all that stuff
you can just start with issue number one
but if what you're wanting to do is get
into Comics Marvel Now is a terrible
place to start because you're gonna be
confused Magneto issue number one Marvel
Now is not going to give you any
indication of how Magneto got to where
he is it's just gonna pick up with
Magneto and he's gonna have his own solo
series and gonna say here's what Magneto
is basically doing now at this moment
and it's just going to keep going in
that going forward in that direction
like that's Marvel Now is is not a good
idea like Captain Marvel Marvel Now will
pick up with Carol Danvers when she
takes over the mantle of Captain Marvel
but like literally Marvel Now like
Captain Marvel issue number one is her
fighting alongside Captain America and
Captain America says you should become
Captain Marvel yeah right the question
that any reader is gonna have if they
start off with Captain Marvel issue
number one is well I mean who is this
and why are they talking to her about
why she should become Captain Marvel
like how did she get to this point where
they say you should take over the role
of Captain Marvel like that's the
problem with Marvel Now Marvel now I
think is really in in all honesty is not
not intentionally but is targeted
towards people who have been following
certain characters who have been
following stories because if you haven't
followed like the X-Men if you haven't
followed Captain Marvel if you haven't
followed you know a lot of these
characters that exist in Marvel now
you're going to be confused when you
start off so I would say that if what
you're wanting to do is to get caught up
on certain characters then send me a
message leave a comment and I will try
to explain that character to you or ask
S or ask Benny and they will do their
best to explain it um in a way that
makes sense so watch like isn't that
what our job is what our job is man is
to make sense of the Marvel my is to
make sense Sal is to is to say [__]
apparently the rant show I explain it as
well tell you it's to tell you why it
sucks funny thing is distilled it where
they were like they were like s will
simultaneously say that it is awesome
and sucks at the same time it's you will
it's funny yeah it is it's like your age
of Ultron thing is hilarious you're like
Age of Ultron was awesome until issue
number two yeah until
this kind Co until Ultron showed up then
I kind of went downhill yeah once Ultron
shows up at Age of Ultron it's pretty
dumb I mean all right see see here's
what I loved about Age of Ultron and
honesty I liked Age of Ultron but not
even like the main story I'd like the
tians the tians were awesome because the
tians are like here's everything that
happened like right before issue number
one yeah and so it's like Ultron killing
basically everybody and it really cool I
I didn't read the tians on that one
actually oh the tians are good man you
got to read the tiin don't read the
Spider-Man tie-in because it's okay the
uh so Bendis clearly wrote Age of
Ultron and didn't give a crap about Dan
slot's superior
Spider-Man because he wrote Spider-Man
in that story he's in it and it's Peter
Parker but it takes place now like at
that time so he's super superior
Spider-Man but Bendis clearly didn't
care and didn't make the
change and and Slot was like Hey and so
was Marvel they were like people are
actually kind of liking superior
Spider-Man like where does this where
does this fit in and so they gave slot a
tie-in book where superior Spider-Man is
in Peter Parker's mind and he's like
okay I fooled them and now how am I
going to survive this Age of Apocalypse
like nothing happens and it's just a way
for you to justify
superior spider it's a way for you to
justify bis's laziness and it's just so
transparent I was like well I remember
the Spider-Man tyin cuz he got because
he I don't I don't know if it was a
tieing or not but when superior
Spider-Man went with them to go do what
they're doing you know to run off and go
do the whole entire Mission and
everything like that and he like he
almost sacrificed someone because he was
going to try and win the war himself and
stuff that I mean that was pretty cool I
mean idea but clearly he doesn't care
like it was that was there was an
afterthought like that was that was slot
being creative whereas Bendis is like oh
yeah you that the thing with the
nah yeah somebody comment they were like
V and yeah Bice and continuity are like
oil and vinegar it's they don't go hand
inand but no like like the problem with
Age of Ultron with with some of the ties
some of the ties they were just totally
pointless like there's one I don't I
don't remember what it's it's X-Men Tian
but it has nothing to do with the X-Men
it's um uh King the Conqueror and the
apocalypse twins and like he takes them
from their future and brings them to the
present and is like you guys have to
learn how to like be dark and kill
people and so like he has them go and
like like kill I think they kill havoc
and they kill a couple other people who
were like the morlocks I think at that
time or they're operating as like
they're an underground group and um no
it's not to but they're like they're
like an underground group of some kind
and um like like one of the Apocalypse
twins is like I can't do it and like the
other one picks up for him like picks up
the slack and so like they go back to
Kane the Conqueror and he was like you
hesitated when it mattered most like I'm
going to send you back to where you were
so you can like be in the like be
tortured again or something it's it's
stupid man it's like the dumbest thing
ever it's it's there's no there's no
reason why that needs to be in the Age
of Ultron I don't understand it at all
like the apocalypse twins are stupid
anyway but um no it's it's interesting
like it's the tyan I think are the
coolest ones really if you're going to
read the tyan for the Age of Ultron the
only one I would suggest you read is
fantastic for tyan it's really the only
one that matters the most so yeah um
okay so black paes Buck pones wants to
know if Final Fantasy 14 got any better
because uh being play in the background
over there uh yes it did
anyway I stopped with 13 that's what I
told Benny last time I was talking to
him um uh Benny my daughter's GNA start
to read Batgirl but I don't know any oh
uh she wants to read Batgirl start with
the new run it's I mean how old is your
daughter how old is she yeah cuz it it
speaks to pre-teen like middle like age
that's what it's all about like we
discussed it last time it's kind of an
awkward book because Barbara Gord is
still 30 but now she's hanging out with
all these 18-year-olds and going back to
college and yeah all about the the
texting and the the Facebooks and that
yeah and yeah and her costume is really
hip and she's wearing very current shoes
matter of fact they're selling the shoes
you know that right yeah you can buy the
shoes that she's wearing but yeah I say
I would say start with that if you don't
really want to get them part of that one
um you can do some of the earlier story
lines but they're a little darker uh
like I would recommend uh Batgirl year
one she's 11 there you go so yeah I
actually I would avoid a lot of the new
52 run because she kind of got in the
darker path with Batman where she fought
the Joker and Joker was like tormenting
her and then she fought her her brother
the new Batgirl run seems to be kind of
aimed at a younger crowd yeah the new
Batgirl book is great it is a good start
especially if she's 11 that's that's
okay yeah um but I really would
recommend back ear year one it's a trade
you can pick up it came out like uh like
11 years ago but it's really really
great and it really gives you a nice in
introduction to the Barbara Gordon
character and it's fun and it's like
really terrific art and it's a terrific
book for anyone especially a a girl
looking to get into the mainstream DC
Universe yeah so it' be like a mom
acting like her daughter yeah basically
that's what's going on with it right now
I think they might wrestle bit now hold
on TV Little House Don't Look Down but
there's a kitty cat behind
you that's yeah it's a little behind now
but my sidekick over here kick it's 48
minutes past his dinner time so he's
like really he's giving me passive
aggressive looks I'm
hungry like where's my food at yo um all
right well I think the questions kind of
drying up at this point we're kind of
going onto our usual hour and a half
kind of time limit right here uh what do
you say marble explain do you want to
call it for the night yeah we can call
for the night then you can go attack the
moth in your house moth was attacking
I'm gonna run out of my I'm the down man
scw he never GNA record again until dies
on its
own screw that man not dealing with
moths the most vicious bug in the world
a moth the most vicious creature like I
imag like Steve ir's like oh my God like
we're here in Lexing Kentucky like
visiting a moth like we have to be very
very
crazy uh so as usual we're going to end
the show like we always do explaining
what we what we're doing for the week um
with it being Thanksgiving week I think
a lot of us are going to be kind of
going on the videos for this week um but
on top of that
like but on top of that the fact that we
are going to go light on videos we do
still have stuff coming out and uh we'll
be back next week at the same time about
400 PM Eastern with the show like usual
so Rob why don't you explain what's
going on here at Marvel
explain uh the road to Age of Apocalypse
continues um we have our last video
coming up for the groups so we're going
to be focusing on uh on no no we don't
we don't we have two we have two left we
have uh The Four Horsemen which is
coming out and uh coming out next and
then after that is the Marauders and
then once we're done with the Marauders
then we're going to focus on the
individuals the first person we're going
to do is going to be uh going to be
Magneto actually I meant to do Magneto
first so we're going to do a video
explaining Magneto which I think people
will really enjoy I have a question that
all of your viewers are probably asking
Rob and I'm going to I'm going to
officially ask it here on the podcast
for them when are you going to get to
the Age of
Apocalypse
man it's going to be it's going to be a
while like I told people I told people
when I when before this even started I
said this is yeah I was like this is not
we're not going to get to the Age of
Apocalypse within like
like three weeks like we're gon to be
doing we're gonna be explaining a lot of
stuff like so much stuff how much stuff
and and people people were like people
were like yeah like I'm so excited it's
going to be so awesome and now there at
that point people are like oh my god
when is age of apocalypse going to
happen it's like man
you yeah it's like it's it's believe me
guys we're just getting started
like you guys have no idea what you
bought yourselves in for
like yeah we're in for that ride Rob all
right um s what are you doing over at
the TV Little House crew and and or set
and or family and I don't even know
anymore what you guys are uh over at TV
little house we uh we've just finished
uh this week we will be releasing an
episode of back issues
tomorrow off the rack comes out we did
Thor number two Thursday's back issues
will be uh this is just for the chat
here we did uh the third
Robin uh I have a old collected volume
of the first like Robin Oh you mean like
his run explaining Tim well not the
whole run just the first minseries and
introduction of Tim Drake okay all right
and uh and next and for thanks and on
Thanksgiving you will get another
episode of back issues um and for the
rest of the week we'll do tangents which
is just me and the guys shooting the
[__] okay uh over at my channel um this
week's a little bit wonky um I've got a
I've got a few uh sponsored things I got
to put out involving a Star Wars where I
explain the extended universe and the
Star Wars Universe um I'm also put it I
just put out the 60k thank you video for
hitting 60,000 subscribers and uh me
eating a bunch of hot wigs um I also
cleared the issue with Marvel and now
the Deadpool videos back up along with
all the original sin videos and uh will
finally be able to continue that Series
so I'm debating what's going to happen
with that but this week the big story
I'm putting out is Superman doomed and
reading through Superman doomed again I
forgot how much fluff is in this goddamn
series like I love I love the story but
there's literally disposable comics in
the thing I'm going through I'm like
okay take a panel write this part of the
script this is what happens here that
was useless delete
gone we didn't need that yeah so we'll
see how it ends jabon said it what's
your question jabon my God I'm terrified
to know what he's going to ask but the
uh kill yourself yeah but uh what's it
called um the Superman Doom story line
should be coming out tomorrow um if I
run into very more hit any more hitches
with it I'll probably have to put it out
Thanksgiving morning
so trying not to do that but we'll
see
word good enough guys Ethan says Notice
Me Senpai to you rob yeah I know I I saw
that I was yeah you're his Senai I guess
is that Ethan from T little house or
just
some it's not ours I'm pretty sure
Ethan's last name isn't Lopez oh I
didn't know I mean I have no idea yeah I
mean I didn't I had no idea anyway um
yeah also keep in mind guys um when it
comes to the website
um let's try this again when it comes to
the when it comes to the website and and
your desire to be a contributor um email
uh s myself and Benny um s got a whole
bunch of emails at this moment um any of
the emails that we get from you guys
we're forwarding to S but we're also
looking at them too so um just keep in
mind uh you know just bear in mind guys
just because you sent us an email
telling us you want to be a contributor
doesn't mean that you will be it just
means that we're reading your emails um
and we're looking at what it is that you
have going on um if s sends you a reply
then just do whatever it is he ask you
to do so yeah uh and if I haven't got
back to you is just because I'm sifting
through the bulk yeah honestly we we've
only we've we've only been secretly
announcing this on the the weekly poast
podcast like it hasn't been announced
anywhere else and Sal's already sifting
through like 50 60 emails so he's pretty
much see who reading everyone's
submissions talking about it he's sent
it and everyone will eventually get a
yes we want you to do stuff or no uh I'm
sorry but you're not what we're looking
for right now email there will be an
actual response so just let everyone get
to that which I do want to go to the
promotion up uh this this podcast is
becoming a website where you will see
all of your favorite YouTuber comic book
guys we're trying to get more of them
not just us I'm not trying to tote just
us um we're talking to quite a few other
on wants to join us onto a centralized
comic book entertainment website of all
of your YouTubers plus some articles and
fun things to do in a community it's
going to be the weekly pool.net it's
launching January 1st if you go there
right now there is a placeholder um so
if you want to be a part of this in any
way shape or form even even if you just
want to be a for moderator or that kind
of a thing email us I'm uh comicstorian
gmail.com Marvel explained is Rob at
Marvel explain. comom and S is s tvhouse
this is a lot this is already blown up
to a much larger scale than we were
expecting so it's taking us some time to
get back to people but but we are we are
getting it done we're getting it set up
and uh we're excited I hope you guys are
excited too yeah rad oh I I want to make
one last thing I'm putting the challenge
out there for the two of you to come up
with a Christmas oriented superhero
story oh God that Blain now I have
already picked the lle trying to steal
the Christmas spirit story oh I know
what I know what I'm gonna I know what
I'm gonna do okay I I'm going I am going
to do oh I got I can't remember what
issue it is I think it's X Factor issue
number 25 at the end of the episode or
at the end of the at the end of the
comic um it's apocalypse returns with
his four horseman and he at at the very
end he's he's got a glass in his hand
and I think caliban's a more like or as
a as a Horseman at this point too but um
they've all got their glasses and like
they're toasting and apocalypse says
Merry Christmas X minute it may very
well be your
last I really want to do that story so
do that we all got to do Christmas I am
doing that and and I'm going to cook the
l f Orange Lantern cookies on mine so
you get I'm up in the I'm throwing the
challenge out there beat my Christmas
video guys you have a month to come up
with a better plan well I've already got
a Christmas special that's a that's
cheating that is cheating that is
cheating you need to do a Christmas back
issues that's cool I will be doing a
Christmas back issues but we will also
be coming out with a Christmas special
that we do every year this will be the
fourth year we do a Christmas special
come to the channel check out the last
time follower oh god dude like the last
I I was looking at the thing I like I
like how there's just like this it looks
more like a sketch comedy thing like a
variety thing that's what we used to
that's what we were starting to be
that's what TV Little House started out
trying to be was we were GNA be like we
would just make videos with everybody um
my my favorite one all right if you guys
if you guys here haven't seen haven't
seen you guys need to go over to TV
little house and look at him there's one
the one that I saw had um there was one
skit with Ben and Ben was talking about
how uh what was he talking about like
free food and stuff and he was uh the
the one where he talking about going
like a homeless shelter and getting free
food oh yeah that's the last that was
Christmas 365 that's where he yeah yeah
yeah he's like just go there and like
tell him like you have crippled children
something like that did he's dressing up
as a homeless person dressing up as a
homeless person that's my favorite one
for those of you guys wondering what
we're talking about go to the really old
episodes on TV little house and you'll
see what what s was doing before we
found him and he was like I can just
talk about Comics all day okay yeah go
to the episode we have the teaser for
the last time follower in the
description we have a link to each
Christmas
special so there you go okay yeah it was
Issue Number 27 Chris thank you Chris
okay all right and on that note we're
going to end this episode of the weekly
pull as usual we will be back here next
Tuesday at about 4 P.M Eastern if we're
not live that's because Rob is having an
issue like he does every week with his
[Laughter]
computer D you could have just gone with
it I wasn't I wasn't going to go into it
and explain how you couldn't get your
computer to
work anyway you guys can see us here as
usual um thank you so much for joining
us today we appreciate every single one
of you we're thankful for all of you and
if you're in the Kentucky area join Rob
for some turkey and mothr sandwiches on
Thanksgiving Day go to his house he
loves un unwelcome guests you know what
guys the off is there it just went over
the light again no it did it no it
didn't it is
your lights oh my
god I've called it out of hiding all
right guys maybe one day we'll kill this
moth we'll see you guys next time right
here and Marvel
explain Batman that's not Marvel